l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono farage e oggi siamo su
destroy all youmans umani del pianeta
terra attenzione sebbene l'esperienza
sia stata migliorata i contenuti le
circostanze storiche dell'invasione
originale a opera di fusion rimangono
sostanzialmente inalterate le vicine
delle parole bambù la sony non so come
mai ma ho le stesse vines che avevo
quando ho giocato a golf simulator per
quanto realtà questo gioco si è fatto
veramente bene almeno quello che sembra
veramente parlando con le mucche ma cosa
esatto è quello che avrei detto io
ma no ma povero musica ma povera
perfetto questo è un gioco meraviglioso
è una buca non avete animali sul tuo
piano giusto finanziato ma non voglio
uscire le mucche ma la le voglio
uccidere cacchio e vabbè alla provare un
certo lei casa top
porca [ __ ] cerca allora mucche provate
a cagarmi in atti o anche se lo so che è
difficile siete mucche ma quindi devo
fermare la polizia che sta andando verso
la mia navicella jetpack
ma cosa vedo signori che la polizia
venite con me che ci penso io ok allora
signora mi scusi e non doveva chiamare
la polizia è andata prof
la vede lei questa astronave e la mia e
mi piace
se vuoi ti faccio fare un giro ma oggi
non posso fare ne abbiamo fatto tutto
ciò ma ragazzi il gioco pazzesco qui
dove questo che lo 160 volte ma io sono
citato è bellissimo ma pure come ed
estrae alpilles va dai ma non hanno
fatto niente vada ma per quale motivo
non hanno fatto nulla
scegli difficili con gli esseri umani
sito questo vale come quello di banda
valeva come berardinis
eccolo qua a posto adesso andiamo in
città faccia un po di casino serio sta
nei vani militari sta degenerando un
pelo la faccenda salve sorgente cosa sto
giocando
ma cosa ma come open fire signori sono
un alieno incredibile primo morite siete
già morsi niente ho vinto io fiume è la
qui i ragazzi il titolo del gioco
ragazzi ma neanche se schierate tutta
l'armata militare riuscite a votare a
parte che non è arrivato missile neanche
uno neanche mezzo mi sono arrivati solo
colpi di pistola che non è che siano
incredibilmente utili contro di me però
adesso chi mandate visto che c'è stata
una una sequenza di persone sempre più
minacciose ma non è servito a niente
l'unico che puoi mandare putin putin mi
fa fuori fuga ecco qua bladimir in terra
di russia non fa il cazzo che vuoi o
finalmente l'immagine cominciato
speriamo che duri un bel po sta roba
perché è troppo divertente ragazzi per
giocarci tutto il giorno
missione riuscita come 80 per cento
annega una mucca nella lucidi la moglie
del contadino con un pollo
mi dispiace non essere stato così smart
però spetta signora venga qua doveva
signora doveva che conta sino allora
sente come si fa a fare
ok scusi vada a controllare un attimo
autoscala come la faccenda perché non
come hai già porca trova in mezzo
controlla questi che sono esseri umani
che sono scagliati da una parte
all'altra
oddio controlla che quello non ti
investa che la polizia tra l'altro
doganale ha preso gesù non smetta
passeri oddio aiuto aiuto mi aspetto
tutte che salgo sul corso perché c'è un
po troppa gente adesso la stavo facendo
un po di minzione ma effettivamente
diventa un po difficile controllare la
faccenda quindi saliamo abbiamo già
fatti fuori se difficile sono prima era
uguale a prima
ho fatto un metro ma quindi è un open
world è poi andato per cacchio vuoi e
realtà e io ho fatto ero qua ho
sorpassato solo lago e alla fine ha
negato
va bene ragazzi indipendence day 3 a
terra allora vediamo se esco da solo con
la pistola a fare robe bel gol
c'è un camion solleva il camion giorno
tutto a posto
speravo in un approccio un po più
amichevole però non era proprio il
massimo
l'altro ci hanno dei proiettili che
vanno lenti che tu vuoi schivare le
pallottole ma com'è possibile
oggi è una mamma che gioco senza se ci
sono ragazzi e vabbè madonna
dando aiuto troppa gente cosa devo fare
qui eh vabbè è veramente difficile
ragazzi perché non capisce il sabba usa
e o bellissimo centro perfetto gli
ufficiali in meno confisca nostrana
preda del calciatore è un alieno pero fa
niente file etico riproviamoci voglio
fare una cosa seria
mi scusi da almeno un'altra lingua di
mucca per favore volevo fare un bilancio
tipo nba wow
no mi scusi non volevo io amo lanciato
la gente non c'è ragazzi stesso per me
non userei mai il razzo il raggio
elettrico mai perché troppo figo far
fuori agenti motivano investe esplodi
minchia metà fulmine per far fuori a
la macchina perfetta
casarotto la cosa devo fare qua nel
luogo dell'invasione ho capito ma cos'è
che devo fare
cielo un obiettivo no raga non ho capito
bene dove sto io e la madonna toppan
casinò madonna layun disastro viva gli
alieni questo gioco veramente non darò
mai c'è io penso che stiamo 29 euro
meglio spetti la mia vita grado
c'è veramente piuttosto non andate al
cina ha comprate questo gioco ragazzi
mammamia molto ha fatto bene comunque io
non ho capito cosa proprio dovrei fare
se vole l'obiettivo di questa faccenda
parte il fatto che sto facendo un casino
atroce
basta basta quanta gente minchia muscolo
posso usare contro di me la cavo
ho sperato ci siamo raga disco volante e
let's go ci siamo a dungeon e su due ore
per arrivare al lupo perché non stavo
trova un veicolo parcheggiato questo
sarà un problema quando avrò la macchina
non ricordarmi dove avrò dove ho
parcheggiato per ora ci sono nei giochi
di alieni meno male
ok ok ho fatto un disastro non ho ben
capito cosa abbiamo
quale è l'obiettivo a parte l'invasione
ho capito ma da che partita vi dove
iniziò ci sarà un inizio
io sono qua di date definite obiettivo
che non ce l'ho orco demonio vedo che
c'è un raggio qua non ho capito bene che
cosa serva a terra si può atterrare dove
vogliono possono atterrare nei brutti
prestabiliti per caso perché sarebbe
stato molto interessante ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta ho disegnato un pene gigante
questo quello che volevo fare questo
potuto fare da alieno disegnare un pene
è stato molto istruttivo grazie seguito
il mio canale iscrivetevi per altre per
altri contenuti positivi avere ragazzi
questo era il primo episodio di faccio
casino con l'alieno vero che vi sia
piaciuto nel senso che dovendo trovo un
gioco soprattutto dispositivo 9 queste
cose potrebbero succedere speriamo di no
fatemi sapere se ne volete un altro
anche perché c'è un sacco di roba da
fare il suo gioco deduco da quanto sia
fatto bene invece ne da giocare
sicuramente però che vi sia piaciuto
anche questo è un mi piace anche risorse
come descrizione se non se da questi
schiette vi era che come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi bella per gli alieni
[Musica]